so
see python is a computer program like
many others it's written in C hence the
name
and it runs on a computer so in order to
make it faster it helps to understand
first of all how the computer runs on
Works some understanding of the hardware
is helpful we don't need to be able to
build a machine or maintain it but we
need some sort of feeling for its
performance characteristics and how they
work
now a button CPUs are complicated things
this is an architecture diagram it was a
slightly out of date machine
um but I want to bring your attention to
a couple of things first of all it's
multiple core but that doesn't really
interest us because of the infamous Gill
but even if there wasn't a girl
the uh we'd expect each core to be
running a separate thread so all these
uh
the optimizations we're going to talk
about would only really apply to one
thread anyway but what is interesting is
that within each core there is
parallelism
uh every time an instruction is fetched
it's several instructions usually
fetched at one time and the multiple
instructions are dispatched there's
multiple execution units in each core
allowing you to do several intro
operations or several floating Point
operations or several memory accesses uh
concurrently
um and that's kind of interesting thing
about these CPUs they're called
superscaler for this reason
um the other thing that's important is
memory access is important now is slow
now if we go back to the previous thing
there's no real memory on here but
you'll see elements of caches and those
caches are there to speed up memory
access
um it takes a long time for light to
move around if you're clocking at five
gigahertz
in five gigahertz light moves six
centimeters it's not very far and
electrons move considerably slower than
that
so it takes physically it's just
impossible to make memory access fast as
just a physical limitation so the way we
work around the CPUs work around is they
have layers of cash they have a tiny L1
cache and I mean tiny as in a few
kilobytes and that's only four Cycles
delay then there's a L2 cache which is
typically 10 Cycles uh L3 cache which is
larger still and shared but across the
cores and that's usually used for sort
of intercore communication that's 30
cycles and then Ram is a couple hundred
Cycles
these superscalar CPUs can work around
the delays and they can push forwards
some execution While others are delayed
but as a first sort of General principle
we want to avoid memory accesses
the exact details are very hard to work
out trying to get precise timings is
extremely hard on Modern Hardware but
just bear in mind a simple thing that if
you have
uh a memory access it's generally going
to be slow
and
because as I said the superscaler it's
dependent memory access is the thing we
really want to avoid so if we have two
memory accesses and we can do both at
the same time because they're
independent the CPU can largely do them
at the same time if we have a memory
access that depends on another memory
access in other words we need the data
from the first one to work out where to
look in the memory for the second one
that's going to be doubly slow
okay
now back in 1976 uh Nicholas vert was
famous computer scientist he wrote this
textbook
it's called algorithm Plus data
structures equals programs which allows
a slightly fuzzy picture I got a hammers
in there
um
now
I just want to sort of split this thing
into two so there are basically before
object-aunted programs which kind of
merge the whole concept of data
structures and algorithms
this was a kind of important way of
looking at programs and it still applies
to sort of low level systems stuff like
C python or Linux or Windows or other
things like that
um so we're going to sort of split this
talk into two the sort of data
structures part
and algorithms
so first of all we're going to look at
the data structure so we're going to
look at some data structures in C Python
and how we've changed them in 311 for
better performance
right but before we get into real data
structures just a little quick uh sort
of aside just as I give you a feel for
this sort of thing
so a linked list is a data structure you
might be familiar with from your
computer classes or from bad job
interviews where they ask you to
implement a linked list
and as you can see from the the image
and comparing with an arraylist it's
quite an inefficient structure
it's inefficient in a couple of ways so
suppose we want to access the integer
two at the second in index two in in the
list
in the arraylist on the left which is on
the left isn't that yes the arraylist on
the left we need to follow four links
and because we're following a link we
need to read the memory
uh in the head to point to the link once
we've read that we know where the link
is and then we could read the memory in
that so this is four dependent memory
loads to get two
if we look at the arraylist on the right
it's only the two loads
still dependent but it's only two
and not only that every time we want to
add an element to the list we need to
allocate more memory now allocating
memory is another slow operation I mean
not for physical reasons just because
there's lots of code involved
um
so yeah so just sort of Designing the
data structures to avoid these dependent
loads and excessive memory allocations
is kind of important
uh but before we look at the
implementation of any data structures I
just want to give you a quick refresher
on uh frame stacks and frames in Python
whenever you call a python function we
need somewhere to put the values in the
local variables any temporary variables
the X the reference to the module
globals and a few other bits and pieces
and these go in a frame object
this Frame contains what I've said no so
what it contains and so every time you
call a python function we take a create
a new frame object and then it calls
other python functions that pushes frame
objects and so on and so we form a stack
frame objects
now no I use the term stack here because
in Python 310 and earlier we have this
which is awfully like the linked list
example I gave you as before now this
isn't as bad as the linked list because
we only ever really want to access the
top frame that we're currently executing
so we don't have to worry about the sort
of extra cost of following the links but
we do need to worry about the memory
allocation we're allocating memory each
time now in Python 310 earlier there was
some sort of caching involved but
conceptually we still have to do his
allocation and even with the caching
it's not as efficient as it could be now
the point is this is a stack
so we implement it as a stack in 310. so
in 310 we just allocate a big chunk of
memory per thread it's actually sort of
several link chunks because we don't
know in advance how big the Stack's
going to get
but in almost all cases we can just
allocate a fret a new frame by just
reusing the memory in that chunk
now this has a number of advantages and
we still need the sort of Link pointer
to follow which I'll come to and why we
need that in a minute
um
but it's still much faster than
having to chase around memory just
because we can compute the offsets from
one to the other
but also what I was saying earlier about
caches
the thing with a stack
is that the bit you're just using is
probably the bit you've just used for a
previous function so it's still in the
cache almost certainly which means as
opposed to a new frame which might be
anywhere in memory and may not be in the
cache so the cache performance of this
is about as good as you can get
and we're not having to do a new
allocation for each time we call a
python function
but you may be wondering doesn't this
change the python semantics I don't
think some of you will have used
sys.getframe
um unfortunately we've all have
encountered exceptions
uh and exceptions came with a trace back
and that traceback includes frame
objects so how do we do with this
so what we do in this case
is we when we need to we allocate a
frame object
so
you can imagine that I've only just
shown the frame object for the the frame
on the top of the stack but you can
imagine ones for each in each frame you
can imagine that we'd allocate a frame
object for each one the one in yellow
and the lower one in white
and we would link those as if they were
the previous ones so effectively we
could sort of lazily recreate this sort
of Stack if we need to
so basically this is a general principle
of sort of optimization we do we
design it so that the special the usual
case the common case is fast
and
make sure that we can continue to
perform correctly for the less common
case even though the less common case
might end up being slightly slower than
it was in earlier versions
so typically normal execution becomes
faster and raising an exception becomes
a tiny bit slower
unless your code is
odd shall we say you would expect that
reception should be relatively rare
um I mean we're given example earlier if
you sort of look before you leap thing
where you exceptions have become a
little more common
but generally you know they're still the
rare case and those pieces of code are
not typical code anyway you will have
some of them in your code base but in
terms of sort of execution counts
they're rare
one other thing you may have noticed in
this is it looks like I might be
cheating by dropping a few things here
to make it look smaller but one of those
is so there's a debug information in
there which we lazily allocate in the
frame object here
and the other is the exception stack now
the exception stack we've dropped in 311
because we have what's called zero cost
exceptions zero cost exceptions is their
technical name obviously they're not
really zero cost because nothing is but
they're pretty close
so why exceptions worked in 310 is that
if you had a try accept statement the
the uh what would happen is when you hit
the try statement the try
we would push a little uh piece of data
onto a stack internal stack which told
us where to go and what uh how much
stuff to pop off the execution stack if
there were an exception and then we got
the end of the try body that would be
popped off that works perfectly
but it means every time you enter a try
and leave a try you're doing a little
bit of work and we need somewhere to put
that stuff as well those things
so that took up 160 bytes I think and
310 and earlier it was 240 bytes in each
frame
uh which is somewhat wasteful given and
that's because we have a maximum
exception depth of 20. if you try and
write try accepts and let's do 21 deep
in Python you'll get a syntax error
you've probably never done that and I
wouldn't recommend you do
okay so the way it works in 311 is that
instead of pushing these blocks what we
do is in the comp the bytecode compiler
we analyze where the exception would
jump to for each bytecode and then we
just create tables that describe that
and those tables are stored alongside
the normal code
um that's a little bit slower again when
an exception is raised but it has no
real cost when we don't raise an
exception there is a tiny cost obviously
because it just it uses a little bit
more memory in the code object but so
zero cost exemptions you've probably
considered as mostly zero cost
exceptions
okay
so that's frame objects now let's
discuss
the more sort of normal objects so
playing old python object so here's a
plain old python object doesn't do
anything just takes two attributes and
assigns into itself
um
this obviously most python objects look
kind of like this but with obviously
some extra code to actually do something
um so this is a kind of standard python
object so let's look at how this is laid
out in memory
now
python objects I know you may have heard
this probably you can consider python
objects as just a sort of a thin wrap
around a dictionary
essentially they give you that sort of
nice syntactic sugar where you can do
instead of like looking up the item in
the dictionary by its sort of quoted
name
you just do a DOT name attribute lookup
um that's sort of one way of looking at
it I mean we don't necessarily think of
them in that way but every object has
this done detect attribute which will
allow you to get it is in dictionary but
almost all code Nev doesn't actually
access the dictionary directly it's very
rarely used
um another thing we need to consider
about python objects is that they are
not fixed size now
what I mean by that is not that they can
have a variable number of attributes
because as you just said they kind of
belong in the dictionary
but it can also have other things that
sort of change the size of the the
python object doesn't become relevant in
a second when I show you the diagrams
uh objects couldn't inherit from
built-in things like an integer or that
you can have done to slots which change
the layout of the object so that's a
little tricky
so a naive implementation this can be
rather slow and bulky so here's the
naive implementation we haven't had a
knife implementation since python 3.2
but I'm going to show you anyway because
I think it's illustrative of the sort of
overheads and the sort of the the sort
of logical simple way of of implementing
this
so you have an object and has a pointer
to its class in its dictionary basically
except that because it's variable size
the pointer to the dictionary isn't at a
fixed offset so we need to look up what
the offset is in the class
now the color the light green color
basically is because that's our shared
instances in other words there's one of
those per class so if you have a
thousand instances of a class or a
million uh there's only one of those so
that's in green because their memory
cost is effectively amortized but per
additional object is zero the red ones
however
are redundant information per instance
in other words there's stuff we really
don't need but we want to get rid of so
basically you've got your object it's
got its class
it's got
um a dictionary and those dictionaries
is basically an array of keys hashes and
values
so if you put a
a
value in an object so we go back to
ourself.a equals whatever
the object's dictionary conceptually has
the value
is stored under the key a and they'll be
indexed somehow or other
and then there's we use a hash table
lookup and so on there's plenty of other
talks on how dictionaries work
now in three ten in three three and
onwards we change this so that the
remove the Redundant keys and hashes
they're moved into a separate data
structure which is shared across the
class in most cases
and then we have this
so now we just have we've got rid of a
lot of the redundancy there we now have
this table of values the keys and hashes
are a separate thing
and that's usually accessed from the
class where it's sort of cached
and then we have the dictionary that
points to those but you'll see there's
still some in Red so
we still have to go okay so one other
thing is if we want to access key zero
value zero here no we have to follow
there's four memory accesses we need to
get the class we need to get the
dictionary offset of the class we need
to use that dictionary offset to find
the dictionary pointer in the object we
need to follow that to the dictionary
and then we need to follow that to the
table
in 3-3 we use less memory but we still
have the three three to three ten we
still have that number of interactions
we still have to follow all that
thing so the first thing we do in 311 is
move the pointers so we can there's
nothing physically stopping us putting
pointers in front of like the header of
the object
so we move the dictionary pointer in
front of that and that means it's a
fixed offset which means we don't need
to look up its offset so this is the
first thing and we've already reduced
the number of uh interactions to get to
our values to two
we haven't saved any memory yet
the second thing we can now observe is
that that dictionary is redundant
it has a pointer to a keys well we can
add the pointer to the a point to the
value sorry but we can add a point of
the values to the object
it has a header but it just tells us
it's a dictionary well we know it's a
dictionary as a point of the keys but we
can already access the keys via the
class
so we can just drop that
and this is what basically a python
object when you just created given the
example I gave earlier just the simple
this very simple thing
and it will give us this so this is our
nice sort of compact form in three three
eleven
okay so that's the data structures it
was a bit of a whirlwind tour I realized
and it'll get won't get slower uh okay
so algorithms
so first of all bytecode bytecode is
what The Interpreter runs when it's
running your Python program again
there's plenty of talks on this but I'll
give you a very brief refresher or
introduction depending on whether you've
seen this stuff before so take the
function on the left it Returns the a
attribute of its argument
the bytecode on the right ignore the
resume that's just sort of a
administrative internal thing to just
Mark the beginning of a function
what it does is it loads the local
variable self onto the evaluation stack
and then replaces that with the a
attribute of that value and then it
Returns the value on top of the stack
in this case
actually no just carry on okay so this
is Pep 659
uh specialized the specializing adaptive
interpreter now this is kind of the
headline feature of 311.
um
but the reason I did the day structures
first is because much of what this does
depends on how those data structures are
put together and laid out
uh as I said earlier it's the number of
memory access that we do is often key
performance
and designing our data structures to
allow us
to do stuff fast it's kind of important
before we can actually do things fast
so especially if I'm adaptive
interpreter basically has an idea that
for each bytecode of you know in of
Interest so not simple things like load
fast return value but the complicated
things like looking up an attribute you
know there's a million different ways
you can have a network that's not a
million it's like 13 or something but
different ways of uh attribute lookups
you can have properties methods values
on the attribute values on the class uh
and you know it's a special stuff done
in C code and so on and so forth
so for each instruction we basically
have in two states one is the kind of
general form which we call the Adaptive
form and that's basically just does the
sort of General lookup that we did in
310 and decrements a counter and when
that counter reaches zero we try and
specialize it and we also have the
specialized forms which are customized
for you know particular values or types
of values that we see and those also
have a counter from misses so we don't
know that
um every time you know just because
we've seen integers being added together
we don't know the next time we get to
that addition it's going to be integers
it could be a flowing Point number it
could be strings
uh if we don't see the thing we'd had
before we fall back to the general case
and we decrement the counter this is
where it's adaptive because it can it
flip-flop between these two states
ideally it basically it goes from the
Adaptive to the specialized State and
stays there but you know code isn't
always that straightforward so we need
to sort of cope reasonably efficiently
where the case it isn't
so basically there's the two forms a
specialization where we go from the
general to specialized form and
de-optimization where we go from the
specialized form to the optimized form
so before we get there the sort of
quickening form so
going back to
this sort of bytecode I'm just gonna
that bytecode is the one on the left
there and I've added a few little things
so actually internally we have some
what's called inline caches a little bit
of space in between some of the byte
codes for putting like data that we kind
of need to speed things up
the quickening form is we change the
basic straightforward form the load
attributes of this load attribute
adaptive and it's basically the same
thing it does the same thing but it has
this counter so we get to the point
where it has this warm-up counter and
the warm-up counters reaches one
now next time you execute the Walmart
counter hit zero and we specialize so
the Adaptive form on the left and the
specialized form on the right
now
assuming we're specializing the function
we should show four instances of the
class we showed earlier you know the
simple one that just has the A and B
attributes
we specialize and we have this form
called load attribute instance value
where there's about 10 different forms
of specializations of load attribute
um
that might be wrong but it may have been
right at some point in the past it will
be right at some point in the future
because we keep changing the number
um the load attribute instance value is
for this sort of simple case which is a
normal python class nothing special no
properties they're just the values in
the instance
so we have a Miss counter and that says
every time we miss we decrement that and
I wish it gets to zero we'll just go
back to the original form and possibly
bounce around a bit
we have a type version and that
basically says
we're interested in this current state
whether the current state of the class
of the value we're looking at is it as
it was when we specialize the code so
what we do is we add a version number to
all classes and then when we change a
class that gets incremented and then we
can just check the version number as a
sort of quick check and the index here
is the basically the index into the
values array
now we're not checking the keys here
which is an interesting thing and this
is basically a property of the uh the
dictionary Keys which I I admitted to
mention earlier
which is that they cannot have keys
removed from them so once we know the
key is in the dictionary the cached
dictionary keys on the class we know
that it'll always remain in there if a
dictionary if we delete it from the
instance we can just null out that slot
if we change the class the instance so
much that we have to redo dictionary
Keys then we just throw we don't use the
cached form and we have our own thing
okay
Okay
so
I just want to run through how this
works quickly this is unfortunately this
is C code
um
if you're not seeing C code about don't
worry I'll just go through this before
so how this works is so as I said the
objects on the top of the stack so we
pop that off and then we look in its
type and we check the type version
that's just the read the cache and we
have the type version in the cache so we
check on the class
if we don't match we do this what's
called de-opt so we de-opt if this thing
as and de-opt is basically just uh
we I'm just checking the time
so if we de-opt we just increment
decrement the counter sorry and then
fall back to the sort of general form
if we don't do any diops we read out the
index
and then we're done now we have a few
bunch of memory reads here but these are
mostly independent there's one dependent
read in here so this is much simpler and
faster than the sort of more General
case
uh
that's not the only specialization we do
we specialize a whole bunch of stuff
there's a whole bunch of there's the
bytecodes on the left and the sort of
equivalent python code
on the right that we specialize
so
in summary we designed the data
structures to reduce the memory access
and then we design specialized byte
codes
to
for you know Common cases that we're
likely to see and we designed those to
take advantage of those data new data
structures such that you know we can
reduce the cost of a thing so in other
words we have this data structures plus
specialized code equals faster python
uh I'm gonna skip the future because
you'll have to come back next year to
see what we're doing 312 if you can read
really fast there's some of the things
we're going to be doing
and thank you
[Applause]